thank you guys for for coming to this
and have an interest in the talk I hope
to
it informative and helpful for you guys
first off and I was telling Tom and
anais this before before coming up here
in a prep call that it's really special
to be here because five six years ago
when i was living in Cape Town South
Africa I would listen to these podcasts
and man it was i was literally ten
thousand miles away but I felt 10,000
miles away from the center of gravity of
the innovation that was happening in the
world we live in out here in Silicon
Valley so it is really surreal to be up
here it's really surreal just to be
living in San Francisco and working on
tilt in this part of the world but it's
something that I really owe debt of
gratitude for these podcasts because
I've gotten a lot out and so kind of put
a little pressure on myself to to try to
make this super informative and helpful
and give back to the folks that are
listening to it here you guys and to the
people around the world that that might
be listening in Cape Town South Africa
and and beyond something I heard one
time in a TED talk was to do this right
before speaking and that this is this is
kind of the universal sign for victory
gets the hormones going so I tried to
get up before I speak even if it's right
in front of the crowd so I have slides
but because I know the nature of the
podcast I will walk through or talk
through the slides for everybody the
first thing that I'm going to talk about
too is give you a little background on
tilt where it started what we do and and
why we do it the very high level if I
saw you at a bar or if I saw a college
campus if I saw you you know on the quad
I would tell you that tilt is the
easiest way to collect money from a
group for free but if you're interested
in the sort of space or your
technologist I would actually kind of
put a little bit nuance in a little
nuance on top that i would say we're
building what we think crowdfunding will
be like in a mobile world and our Y
Combinator application it's quite
literally what we applied with was the
answer to a question what will
crowdfunding look like in a mobile world
and
uh we had some icing on top of the cake
beyond that but that was the heart of
what we were trying to design a
bite-sized simplified version of
crowdfunding to our quite literally you
could launch a crowdfunding campaign and
the time it takes to write a tweet that
was kind of the challenge we gave us if
you download the app I hope you see
we've we've gotten close to that the
background those starts probably before
tilt starts in in Cape Town South Africa
I studied development economics and if
you guys don't have that major here you
guys should wake forest had a great
program around development economics
loved the major started work in the
field on the ground in development Cape
Town South Africa in microfinance
micro-insurance and started to kind of
combine my hobby and my passion my
passion was in poverty alleviation my
hobby I picked up in college was web
development so I started to build out a
site called de villota argh developed
org is essentially an online lending
platform that had elements of
crowdfunding for developing communities
similar to kiva.org focused on micro
insurance however and in building that
out in 2009-2010 this one little feature
within that site develop where you could
get family and friends to give with you
and collectively accomplish a thousand
dollars $5,000 collectively accomplished
something you couldn't individually give
that little feature that was it that was
the thing that put it in this brand new
category that was forming called
crowdfunding and it put it kind of in
this is a journalist just codified the
term in 2010 and I started to think man
that I thought this was an online
winning space but this feature this
ability to coordinate your resources on
an unprecedented instantaneous scale
holy s oh say s for my wife she always
gets mad if I cus I was like man this
crowdfunding thing this might be a
decade defining phenomenon so ability to
tap into the collective collaborating
pool our resources on his
scale could be huge if you think about
it in my favorite web products are the
ones that augment our natural innate
behavior as humans you know we've been
pooling our resources for hundreds
thousands of years every civilization I
know of is built on on shared resources
and yet in 2015 or back then in 2012 is
still phenomenally hard to pool your
resources for a neighborhood cause a
awesome party bus with your your friends
a you know if you want to run for mayor
we've we've even had tilts for mayoral
candidates and Oakland Boston Chicago
New York if you want to do that it's not
that easy yet but I felt like you know
this is going to be a really really big
space ultimately developed org long
story short in the online lending space
the SEC change their stance on online
lending that was a swift kick to the
stomach in the model that we had but the
kill shot was it was going to require us
on top of registering his broker
securities it was going to require us to
do about 10 to 15 minutes of paperwork
for every 25 dollar dollar loan so it
made the model pretty untenable came
back to the US pretty discouraged in
fact there was three or four months
there when I thought there's no way in
hell I'm i'm going to start anything
again it is was really really hard to
shut something down after working on it
for two years and but i couldn't shake
that insight of man this crowdfunding
things going to be really really big but
I was kind of content with just being on
the sidelines watching it watching it
blow up before my eyes and see the power
of crowdfunding happen I was kind of
content not doing anything within the
space and maybe going to grad school
saving up to go to grad school and then
go work at the World Bank or IMF work
and development and and then another
insight hit me it was this view that man
he's current crowdfunding platforms that
are really awesome we're still big fans
of them Kickstarter or IndieGoGo these
current first generation of these tools
they're really going to struggle to
translate to a mobile world watching a
five minute video reading nine levels of
rewards reading eight paragraphs that
might be a lot to try to digest on the
bus to work or
car to class so in 2011 was also about
the time that Instagram was blowing up
as this bite-sized mobile mobile focused
version of sharing photos now that point
is kind of moot because they're owned by
Facebook but at that time it was a good
analog of saying okay if we could take
our favorite elements of crowdfunding
but bring it down in a more bite-sized
simplified version built for a truly
mobile world then maybe we can reach the
1.5 billion connected devices out there
half of which will never own a PC now
that numbers three billion if you
actually add a ball to crowdfunding
platforms the major ones us and a few
others there's only a couple hundred
thousand people that have started
crowdfunding campaigns before and yet
there's two billion connected to three
billion connected devices and the world
so that stat as low as well as that that
question that we had early on what will
crowdfunding look like in a mobile world
that was kind of this a second insight
on top of feeling like crowdfunding it's
going to be really big was thinking
through okay what platform or what type
of model will will excel in a mobile
world mobile context started to build
that out in in my bedroom i'm back in
dallas texas any Texans here there we go
all right there we go longhorns nice
sorry about the football season um the
the idea with tilt was actually very
different than how i started developed
or hotel today was a nights and weekends
thing I showed everyone from the the
home page to the first version of it
wanted feedback from people very
different than how i started develop but
in showing it to people and invest her
down in austin texas probably the best
angel investor in austin a guy named
Bill Babel don't de company called
webmail and was bought by Rackspace and
he was in Austin just angel investing
and reached out wanting to invest but he
said in fact he invited me down to
Austin and I drove down there getting
lunch with him walk up to the restaurant
I see this kind of this look at
disappointment and I'm like why is he
disappointing it's like we're we're your
where's your team are
really want to meet the whole team it's
like there is no teams just it's just me
and the look of disappointment really
started to to look pretty more like
despair he's like I saw on the website
says we believe this weird I was like
well yeah I'm handling people's money I
you know we're trying to make it look
legit he's like uh all right let's grab
lunch would grab lunch and we sit down
and he's like I have an investment
thesis that I just can't invest in solo
founders what you're about to do is
going to be so hard it's going to be so
emotionally draining and you know I
actually think about those words I was
like holy crap he was right it's going
to be so hard that you really need a
co-founder and I knew it and wasn't you
know wasn't really resonated with me it
wasn't news but with developed or guy
was bringing anyone everyone that I was
friends with on onto the team I was
handing out co-founder cards like
they're going out of style but with tilt
I was really waiting for the right
person and waited seven months after
started writing the first lines of code
before I brought on co-founder and it
was shortly after this conversation with
bill went back up to Dallas went to
every meetup I could I was the most
technical of my friends and really
didn't I really felt like we needed a
solid short footed CTO for what we're
about to build and reach back out to
Bill and say hey Bill can I come sleep
on your couch down in Austin I'm not
finding anyone up here in Dallas and he
said actually there's a guy here at
Rackspace basically does my job he runs
strategy here he's only 26 and you
should chat with him he is and I'll
never forget the two things he said he
said first thing he said was he is a he
has a rare combination of technical and
strategic thinking and the second thing
he said was he's who I would start my
next company with bill was a phenomenal
CTO technologist and he was saying this
26 year old kid he would bring on his
his CTO for his next company so I was
like all right I got to get this guy I
have to get this guy on board yeah he
finished the call by saying his name is
his name is Khaled come on down and see
if you can get him on board go drive
down to Austin and
by the end of it three hours into this
coffee from 7pm to 10pm by 10pm the
coffee saw a coffee shop is shutting
down and this guy Khaled says all right
I'm putting my two weeks notice tomorrow
and I'm going to quit and join me and
build out this company but that is not
how the coffee started the coffee
started with a very stern very strong
one of our board members is back there I
think both of our board members are
actually here in the audience and they
know how strong Caleb books is pretty
intimidating dude and the coffee started
with his pretty jacked egyptian guy that
i never met before arms crossed saying
all right why am i going to quit my job
tomorrow and help you build a
crowdfunding platform for party buses
and barbecues and bachelor trips it was
a great question luckily I had an answer
for me but but it was a great question
and that question I mentioned in this
story today because it's something we
think about as a company all the time we
actually put a probably a profound
amount of thought into into that
question and why we're building what
we're building how we're building it the
answer that I gave him is the same
answer I get in an interview or
something at at the tilt quarters right
in San Francisco and I told him look
version seven of these things looks very
different than version 1 and they have
to look very different version 7 would
be something like Facebook it was about
six months prior that it was the Arab
Spring so it's just convenient timing
but I was able to save version 7 and
Facebook is powering 14 nonviolent
revolutions two of which afterwards
became violent but 14 nonviolent
revolutions in the world House version 7
version 1 was an application for
voyeurism exhibitionism on a college
campus I remember my freshman year when
it launched it really was just what did
your friends do last night which cute
girls are in the your class on Tuesday
Thursday and it needed to start that way
because it had this every day this daily
utility in our lives when I started
using it there were many social social
networks launched and
coming from the social space coming from
the nonprofit space I made note of every
single one of them and they were all
dead on arrival because they didn't have
that frequency that daily use that
utility in people's daily lives that
Facebook had so in telling him that I
also mirrored Tahrir Square he's from
Cairo and Alexandria so I was able to to
say look when people wanted to protest
the government in Egypt they went to
Tahrir Square they went there not
because the government said okay this is
the designated area for protests now
they went there because that's where
people already were so if we focus on
building a crowd funding application
that's a very accessible kind of bite
sized one way of that it's been
described is kind of a Twitter of
crowdfunding then it's going to get a
lot of people on the platform the first
time you use it might be for a group
birthday get the second time you use it
might be for you know a tailgate for the
game on Saturday third time you use it
might be for for a neighborhood cause
but you're just you're going to love the
platform the product and you're going to
get more and more ambitious in the 17th
time you use it it might be for running
for mayor we've had one of my favorite
tilts of all time was a guy came in
starting use the using the platform saw
his friend using it for a softball
league and then he used it two weeks
later to collect money for private
patrols of his neighborhood in oakland i
joined the campaign because it was so
cool and and it literally the first fray
the first line on the on the tilt was
enough is enough the the the crime in
oakland or part of oakland is so high it
has the largest the highest mugging rate
of the country and it's only eighty two
hundred dollars for four months of
private patrols just someone in a car in
a flashlight and we can see if that'll
that'll help the situation i pitched
into that tilt which the guy came across
it because of a softball campaign now
pitch ended i tilt because i thought it
was so cool and i don't think the guy
knew and he sent out a newsletter two
months later after the first month of
the of the patrols and the newsletter
said that they had cut crime by forty
six percent they had set up a tilt and
in 24 hours had collected 8282 dollars
from 100 households 24 hours and had
used it to cut crime by forty six
percent
obviously I didn't have that data point
when i was talking to kayla in the
coffee shop but it is very much in the
narrative arc of what we thought this
product could be coming if we get enough
people on it and build a really easy to
use crowdfunding application so told him
that and and by the end of the coffee he
was somewhat convinced we moved down to
austin then after that we applied to Y
Combinator came out here and I can't
tell you how jealous I am you guys have
awesome speakers safer today at this
campus all the time I used to ride my
bike up here for four different lectures
saw a phenomenal Peter Thiel debate up
here one night two three years ago and
it is a really cool part of the world we
moved out here and we thought all right
we're going to come out of here for y
combinator and then we're going to when
then we're going to go back to austin
and build the company there but within
two or three weeks we really felt you
know this is where we should be the the
world moves really really fast here and
the ecosystem if it makes it just five
percent easier to build our company here
then that will pay dividends for the
next you know you compound that over a
year that's a pretty big difference so
we stayed out here we really loved it
moved up to San Francisco and we started
to build our team the luckiest the
single luckiest moment we had as a
company I think was the introduction to
my co-founder Khalid and that is a theme
that has run through from from that
introduction to every single person we
have working until it is it is all about
the people i'm going to start talking
about that here in a second the second
thing i'm going to talk about is
perception versus reality and then the
third thing i want to talk about is
clichés which one's actually matter so
perception versus reality let's see if
we can get that there we go all right so
if you haven't used the app super simple
download it you can even just download
it just to see how other people are
using it it's really easy to use
perception versus reality or bricks
versus more you there what are we
looking at
well brick wall exactly that's what I
would have said before we're looking at
bricks but actually we're looking at
bricks and mortar and when I was your
age you know 20 21 I would have said
bricks but I'm gonna talk about bricks
versus mortar and kind of the stuff that
goes in between the bricks that makes
all the difference going back to Z this
slide and and telling for the folks on
the podcast it's just it is just a
picture of bricks and mortar and it is
so easy to look at that photo and think
that's bricks but a law a few years of
doing this I'd say the mortar is more
important they different strain bricks
and mortar is the difference between
just a single finger can push over a
stack of bricks the mortar can help it
withstand a hurricane so in that vein
bricks versus mortar I'm going to talk
about what i thought was really
important versus what I now think is
really important and by the way it's not
about it's not X versus Y and X isn't
important they're both important it's
just that I would have thought X is the
thing I would think about and it turns
out why the why is all I think about a
little wordplay there for you so the
person versus the people the perception
is it's a person that does something
that's what we see on cover of magazines
is a person a face it is kind of what we
see in every heroic novel it is the
person that is the brick that's the
thing that you think it's built on the
mortar is is really the people I would
have thought ok be really smart be it
you know have high integrity have a
can-do attitude persistence and it and
just think about all the qualities of
that person man our company has taken
off the more and more we thought I
stopped thinking about ourselves I
really started think about the people
around us then network around us whether
it is investors that have helped refine
the idea whether it is the recruits that
we brought
they're ten times smarter than ourselves
whether it is even bringing kayla Don as
a as a co-founder it is the person
versus the people the people are the
thing that helped you withstand that
hurricane the people at tilt whether it
is the advisors the investors or our
colleagues that is the most important
thing the people it is all about the
people strategy versus culture Peter
Drucker has a quote that goes culture
eats strategy for breakfast and another
way of looking in this slide is strategy
versus execution to get anything right
you need strategy and execution you need
both and you need to be right about both
you need the X and the y but you end up
thinking a lot more about the culture
the execution and I compared culture
execution kind of like you know when you
meet someone and you have body language
and in their face the 16 different
muscles there's micro expressions and
and you can pick up on these
micro-expressions I look at culture as
kind of these micro microStrategy's how
things are done on a Tuesday what
strategy did someone take culture is
also simply defined as how we treat
people and how we treat each other Bill
Campbell said that I think it's one of
the best definitions of culture how we
treat each other as part of our strategy
treat each other well care about each
other love each other we use the word
love maybe too much of the office but
strategy would be the bricks but the
mortar is the culture results versus
process I used to think winning is
everything in fact one of my favorite
basketball coaches told me winning
solves everything um jack welch's book
is literally titled winning but I think
that's the brick process is the mortar
the this simple line there is focused on
the process and the results take care of
themselves the results are a byproduct
the aim is getting the right process
when we were super focused even just
three years ago on just results we
really lost sight at how can we make
sure these results compound how can we
make sure these results go on for a long
time we really
focused way too much on monthly goals
rather than yearly rather than culture
rather than all the things that that I
think go into process we really focus
too much on results now we focus very
little on results focus all of our
energy on process and we have the best
results we've had today complexity
versus simplicity this you guys are
probably much smarter than I so this one
probably doesn't need to be said but
when I was younger when I first started
listening to these podcasts five six
years ago I thought in terms of
complexity just the world was a
complicated place as complex me you
absorb any marketing any marketing
message in the last few years of any
great company I mean they are trying to
confuse the hell out of you the company
known for simplicity Apple their
marketing message was insanely great
think about what that says to you when
you're absorbing that message it's like
it's so great there's no way I could
ever ever understand how great is it's
insane it's literally insane how
greatness is no no that none of it was
insane it's actually pretty simple or
you see on a brand new product patent
pending I mean this is so complex we
have a patent for it it's never been
done before and that's kind of the
marketing language that I used to
consume thinking that okay the first
version first version of developer had
way too many features luckily it had the
feature where you can invite family and
friends but he had way too many features
and I spent 19 months building it before
I even telling anyone for showing it to
anyone shutter it to maybe five people
before we launched at a business
planning I showed that to everybody but
the actual software showed two very very
few people and I had it wrong it is all
about simplicity simplify simplify
simplify if you're going to build your
own business try to find simple fires
not complicated a lot of people that
subscribe even if you subscribe to
simplicity if you bring on folks to your
team that subscribe to complexity that
are complicated than simplify errs
who you are setting yourself up for a
hard time simplify simplify simplify
journey versus a destination the
destination those are the bricks that's
what we see in movies you see someone
being carried around you see a
presentation that floors everybody you
see or you read in every narrative about
these moments these is a whether it is a
speech that rivals up the crowd or
whether it is an aha moment around an
idea these are destinations I was
consumed with this idea of of if we can
get funding I remember reading a tech
rhetorical of a company that got
investment from andreessen horowitz and
I use the product in the end they got
this investment I was like oh my god
they have made it that the smartest
investors in the world they must know
something that I don't they're just
they're golden now they got investment
now that company is no longer around and
we've raised investment from from I
think the best investors in the world
and by the way on the people slide I
think we've got in all honesty I think
we have the best team in Silicon Valley
and we have the best investors in
Silicon Valley but I thought that was a
destination that once you make it to
that plateau you're you're good you're
golden there was probably more anxiety
the day after we signed our term sheet
with injuries and horwitz than any day
prior the journey is the destination
being able to appreciate all of the
moments in between the mortar within the
bricks that is really where the soul of
the work lives that's where the love is
the the cliches the journey is the
destination and then six months ago I
read an even better version that said
the journey is the destination and the
obstacles are the journey we're so
considerate and this is a ideal that has
some some merit but we're so consumed
with overcoming obstacles the obstacles
are the thing that is where the
resistance lies if we're only concerned
with obviating obstacles are overcoming
obstacles that would be like going to
the gym and never adding weight to the
bar this is their beam
point that resistance is everything that
is what makes you stronger the journey
is the destination heard it a thousand
times and I never could appreciate until
the last few years decisions versus
decisiveness the brick would be
decisions you think an aha moment or a
decision you hear the the story of you
know I remember the story bill gates and
being in the the meeting with IBM making
a deal where they didn't get license to
the software and they could sell it to
other computer manufacturers and that
was this brilliant moment this decisive
genius move it's not the decision that
matters it's being decisive and the
decisiveness and being able to take
advantage of one of the greatest things
you have going for you in starting a
start-up is that you have rapid feedback
loops extremely rapid feedback loops
it's not really about the decision it's
actually about being extremely decided
decisive so you can have feedback loops
on as many things that you've decided as
possible it is one of the greatest
things about starting a start-up is the
rapidity of these feedback loops you
make a decision you try something out
you a be tested you ask a customer you
ask a colleague you can move so quickly
take advantage of that and know the
value the mortar is the decisiveness the
brick is the decision you might be
remembered for the right decision but if
you're successful you know that you made
99 wrong ones but you just made them so
fast that you got to the right one a
great Marine Corps quote on this one is
there's no there is no wrong decision I
know the only wrong decision is in
decision I think it's a great great
quote number versus the trend the brick
is the number the mortars the trend it's
not the number to the trend if I wrote a
book for startup founders i would i
would write it's not the number it's the
trend that is like that's it that's
probably the theme that i think about
most i used to think about numbers i
used to think about headline-grabbing
numbers of man this thing got to a
million customers
this thing got to 10 million users but
it's not the number it's the trend the
saddest graph in the world is one that
looks like this the second status graph
in the world is one that looks like this
there are a lot of viral apps out there
that might get to 10 million users they
might hit a nominal number and it might
sound like holy crap they got it all
figured out but you check in with six
six months later a year later and that
not that high watermarks might still be
there but the trend is definitely going
on the wrong direction that trend is the
health if there's anything that every
single technology company in the world
is judged on whether it's Google or
whether it's to folks in a garage just
getting started it is the trend and it
really simply all comes down to that
trend the thing about this this one is
it allows you to also care a lot when
the numbers are small but the trend is
good if you're just getting started you
know a week over weak trend five percent
six percent ten percent that is much
better than hitting some nominal number
that sounds really big it's not the
number it's the trend and this
correlates the best advice I ever got
from what am I from one of my basketball
coaches it's not how you start it's how
you finish so that I told you the third
part was going to be about clichés but
I've included all the clichés in the
last slides they were the mortar in
between all the slides it's all about
the people culture eats strategy for
breakfast manage the process and the
results take care of themselves simplify
simplify simplify the journey is the
destination the only wrong decision is
indecision and it's not how you start
it's how you finish those seven cliches
they're the mortar I heard all seven of
those a thousand times growing up you
guys have probably all heard them a
thousand times if not 10,000 times and
yet we still look at the bricks
whether it's through trial tribulation
or whether it's through a piece of
advice you can grab from from this
podcast or this lecture it is to try to
see the mortar and maybe take a flyer
and trust me that that mortar is the
thing that you start to look at and
think about much more than anything else
in these seven cliches there are a lot
of cliches that that don't really amount
to truth but I have a feeling these
seven cliche stand the test of time
because they do one last one is a
picture is worth a thousand words this
one's just for fun for those in the
podcasts they can't see we've got users
tilt around the country now around the
world that take the tilt flag up to the
top of a hike just to get a picture with
it one kid actually made a wooden logo
of tilt a replica of our of our logo
it's thats painted on a wooden wall in
our office in san francisco and another
one god save them got a tattoo of our
logo that was maybe a month ago that's
the mortar in between everything that we
do there are decisions there are moments
there are numbers there hires there are
bricks every single day it's so tempting
to look at a graph and think about a
graph in Silicon Valley but it's our
users or customers that we think most
about that we obsess most about these
moments don't show up there the
qualification not the quantification of
what we do and they don't show up in any
graph but it is the mortar we think more
about than anything else and the graphs
really take care of themselves if you
start to think about the process the
mortar and your customers above all else
so thank you and I think we're going to
open up to questions all right if if you
got if you guys having
right any questions real quick any tilt
ambassadors here I think we have a few
uh there we go all right we've got a few
on campus on Sanford Oh tilt ambassadors
so you guys should sign up for the tilt
calm / ambassador we have ambassadors
around the country now in Canada the UK
Netherlands and a few other countries
that that we have we are in beta about
to flip the switch on and there folks
that get to put on their LinkedIn that
they were working for a tech company if
you have interest in working for a tech
company after you graduate then
obviously having something on the resume
and some experience beforehand helps but
even more than that the mortar is they
get to learn about marketing get to
learn about sales they get to learn so
much about our product and how we choose
certain strategies with our product
design we really bringing pretty close
to the vest and show them the inner
workings a lot of them have come through
the office and we've got hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds think we have over
a thousand so yeah telkom / ambassador
if you're interested in in what we're
doing we have questions sure what's the
evaluable I'm oh lord that is to say the
minimum go to set for people's cars get
charged for you to get the funds versus
people just you know their cards are in
charge right off the bat line go find
you yeah so the question was what is
what's the tilt feature all about what's
special about it so you tilt feature
some of these things are you know
whenever there's some secret sauce
entrepreneurs always pretty savvy to
dodge the question but I'll hit it
straight on the tilt feature is is
really important what it allows you to
do is you set up a tilt download the app
and you can set up until 12 13 seconds
to collect money for anything let's say
it's for the tailgate on on Saturday and
the minimum you need is 350 bucks to
make it happen or will let's say it's
you know getting tickets to Coachella or
community cause where you want to fix
potholes that costs two thousand dollars
you don't want to find yourself and if
you use cash checks
paypal venmo you you could find yourself
one hundred and forty dollars in but not
near the goal the amount that you
actually need to fix the potholes the
tilt feature allows the organizer to
have risk-free ability to start
collecting money for that cost so if
it's two thousand dollars until yet the
until you get to two thousand dollars
the cards are just authorized but not
charged once you get that two thousand
twelve dollars a you need for their
fixing the potholes it charges all of
the cards and the money's deposit in the
next day so the the real benefit I know
Stanford uses the app for selling
t-shirts and an apparel for fraternities
sororities homecoming things like that a
lot and the benefit is you might have a
minimum order of 25 shirts that need to
be ordered so you don't want to sell or
start and collect money and you only get
to 11 or 12 or 13 that's kind of a
tactical benefit the psychological
benefit is for the organizer they're
able to toss up a tilts without worrying
about that risk and it greatly lowers
that threshold you know that burden on
that organizer and you don't have to use
the tilt feature by the way you can set
it up to where you you don't use the
future at all though yeah yep Thunder
when bringing someone else in to your
company take this issue of like someone
else working on your baby or something
I've been working for almost a year um
it's simple one I was working on it no
mainly nights and weekends so it didn't
feel like you know my baby it did in
some respects but I had already gone
through that my baby controlling kind of
mindset and it led to a defunct startup
so I think with this one it was it was
much more open you know I think that
control comes from fear and that control
around the in the concept this is my
baby and kind of limiting how many hands
are cooks are in the kitchen comes from
this fear that they're going to take in
the wrong direction or it's going to
somehow hurt the effort the truth is
that takes it takes a lot of
overconfidence borderline arrogance to
feel
like okay if I could do every job then
it would all be great if you bring on
someone better smarter than yourself and
you understand that and I'm going to
have to have trust with letting go of
this thing losing control and so many
different parts of it in the next few
years if you really care about the
mission of what you're trying to achieve
and build something of your massive
significance then you know how many
people are going to have to be on board
so you get pretty comfortable early on
when their hands are are in there
helping especially if you really trust
them to be better than you at what
they're brought on to do but I
definitely believe in separation of
concerns division of labor you really
want to know what you're looking for and
what role that person will have if you
want conflict have two people do the
same job and and so it's it's something
that you really want to find the right
person that allows you to focus on one
thing and they get to focus on the other
and then you don't really think about it
too much you're really glad that
person's there yep so you mentioned that
you study developing economies in school
and that you have a passionate was kind
of idea social good social justice on a
day-to-day basis as a CEO of a tech
company how do you bring that passion
into your work how do i bring my the
passion for the development aspect of my
life or kind of poverty alleviation
passion into my daily work at at tilt
super simple and it actually goes to
kind of an imagery that that that I I
always think about when I was in cape
town and the townships right outside of
Cape Town's called Khayelitsha and saw
pretty much everyone with an android
phone pretty much every single person
2010 had an android phone with Google on
more information in their pockets then
the president united states had 15 years
part of that that's a private tech
company out here in Silicon Valley so I
kind of looked at that and made a very
cursory observation that they've
probably done more for education than
any education organization that's ever
exists in the history of the world by
doing what they did feeling like it was
a vocation more than just a job and a
craft
them work and and they're able to put
more information in our pockets than the
the rest you know that then the
president united states had 15 years
probably that sounds hyperbolic but it's
it's probably accurate and so when I
think of tilt and I think about how it
can impact the world as a company we
care so much about our mission probably
to a radical amount that we openly say I
openly say that if some other company
comes along can achieve our mission
better and we can then if we really care
about the mission and that's good for
the world our mission is to power the
collective creation in the world and it
really goes to this problem we feel
deeply passionate about is just this
this high difficulty and inability to
participate in the creation of the world
around us you want to change something
on campus it's really hard you want to
fix potholes in street appeal of the
city for two years you want to improve
the safety of your neighborhood best of
luck with tilt it allows you to have and
take something that's happening in
parallel that we think a lot about and
that is this is self-organization of all
of us into various communities online
that's happening right now in the view
and the big bet is these commuters are
going to want to do something with these
connections they're going to take
collective voice and add collective
muscle to it so if you add to answer
your question most directly if you add
time to the equation 5 7 17 years then I
think it directly will impact
development ask from whatever yep so
speaking of ethics to you guys in
moderate at all what you can set up
until four so someone's if it so for
pornography it work for you know I KKK
rallies you guys step in there and if so
where you draw that ethical line yeah
the question was around great question
all these are great questions question
was around where do we draw the line on
what we allow and don't allow on the
platform thematically I'd say openness
and accessibility are tenets of how we
build software openness and
accessibility so from the openness angle
we want to be able to provide software
for anyone and everyone that might have
things they might think differently and
we do they might care about things
differently than we do there are some
ground rules that we care deeply about
knits no firearms
no gambling no pornography but outside
of those very limited things it's really
up for people to use however they want
and that's really important to us as a
software developers the accessibility
part is both it being open and
accessible but it's also getting it out
into the world in as many pockets as
possible and I'm sure we're going to
have we're going to see it and we have
seen it be used for things that we might
not agree with but we don't think we
should be the arbiters of how this
technology should we use yep well
something like processing payments is so
core to your business how do you pick
who you partner with the power payments
and how do you build that relationship
as you grows camp as a great question to
the question was around how do we pick
payments partners you know we look at
payments kind of like we look at server
infrastructure it's a similar to AWS we
look at payments partners as kind of an
infrastructural technology beneath our
social layer and it's really important
as are our servers it's not quite where
AWS is so we have a number of partners
that we work with but we develop pretty
strong personal relationships with them
because for them for the most part we're
asking them to process on a crowdfunding
realm that's really new and when we
started the company we got shut down by
three different processors I was some of
the scariest nights were going to bed
and and thinking that I will might wake
up tomorrow and a very important part of
the businesses is no longer there that
was only three years ago so it's it is
it is caught up quite a bit but stripe
for example only started allowing stripe
and Braintree to the biggest processors
out there only start and paypal only
started taking on crowdfunding in last
one or two years so we've kind of really
pushed the limits and been on the
bleeding edge of of that technology and
there's a great payments coming I want
to give a shout out to call it balanced
payments that is a scrappy 11 person
team that is no longer around but they
took a bet on us as a client
and we went eternally grateful for him
because at that point especially going
through why commoner we had nowhere to
turn so we've had to form deeply
personal relationships with with these
folks one in Europe we we got so close
that a person reach out and said can I
join your team and he sent as yes any
favorite tilt as a great question and my
view on I've got too many one of my
favorite ones recently 133 northwestern
students I might get some of the details
wrong but 133 northwestern students this
is really recently unless maybe a week
or two ago they they got tickets to a
blackhawks game 133 friends and the
reason I find that cool is that just
wouldn't happen without tilt just trying
to coordinate an experience the 10
friends going to a blackhawks game going
to a concert together that is it if
you've ever been that organizer and
pretty much all of us have tried that
and then we were so stung by tour like
I'm never doing that again that that
it's a huge headache to see 133 people
be able to go to something and have an
experience together and we've had a
maturation or views of these group
experiences that I used to think it was
all about nonprofits and getting to that
that realm as quickly as possible touch
on that question in poverty alleviation
but I read a study one time that said
the peak of human existence and studied
10,000 people on their deathbeds and
said the peak of human existence the
mount is the moments in it and
experiences we share with the people we
know and love and so building software
that allows that to happen much more
often more seamlessly there actually is
a very special part of sort of really
find those tilts would be really cool to
watch but my favorite one maybe more on
the social side is we have an enterprise
tool called open tilt open where you can
bend and flex and customize a brand it
however you want it's built to be kind
of the WordPress of crowdfunding powered
by our API and only a few of our folks
work on it but it's powered some of the
biggest crowd funding campaigns and
projects of all time tens of
millions of dollars in one of which was
for an AIDS vaccine and you heard me
right aids vaccine being crowdfunded and
they still have I think six or seven
more trials to go but for their first
one the crowd funded it using our
software that's pretty phenomenal and
shows shows kind of the future I hope of
what told becomes good one more Yeah
right over here or a few more if we got
the time you were raised 67 67 million
or something knighted and started with
two and then 12 and 20 and 30 can you
how does it feel due to start with two
and to prove the concept and what do you
need to go to the next step what are the
essential parts to grow a company and
nice that you have my messages in
Hollands I just came from hormones all
right they were young your I'll be your
second or your 100th basinger perfect
what's your name Vincent Vincent all
right i'll send you the slide deck i
just presented a few minutes ago that'll
tell you all the things that i think
about in between those funding
announcements that's the oh that really
is the the genuine thing is we think
about all of those things into building
the company we think about the people
it's the reason the first slide was
about the people it is all about the
people hiring the right the right people
in a fast going starved it's really
really hard to find great people on top
of that in this environment it's really
hard to find great people but keeping
the bar high has been one of them it's
been the most important thing we've done
and spend the thing we've been luckiest
on yeah yep oh right here
does her grave okay I just go outside
please Anna Kendrick's Android I'm done
for you anguish competition yeah so the
question was how do we distinguish from
the competition one I'll repeat that you
know it really is true in our book all
crowdfunding is good crowd funding so
whichever platform you use and we're big
fans of I mean I wore big fans of a lot
of them and know a lot of the team
members really love them our version is
really built for a mobile world so in
its in its kind of another way of saying
is we've taken our favorite elements of
crowdfunding but provide it for groups
and communities that already know each
other to be able to toss up a
crowdfunding campaign from your phone
really easily and be able to tag your
friends to it it sounds crowd funding
from your mobile phone sounds really
hard but we've worked tirelessly and a
lot of smart people come together to try
to build and I think we we built a
pretty simple beautiful solution for you
to collect 25 ten thousand dollars we've
had campaigns collect hundreds of
thousand dollars using the application
yes um you probably do a lot of base
management and it's always you marry me
to start you know honey um what is your
biggest worry as to why what is my
biggest worry to why tilt might fail one
day and and what's the risk management
there so yo going back to the bricks
versus mortar analogy I would think I
would have thought it's things like
competitors I would have thought it's
things like you know getting funding i
think it's the truth is you know when we
were starting the company going through
y combinator we looked at the two
luminaries dropbox and Airbnb and one
was an engineering centric brand and one
was a and one was a design centric
branded we thought okay which one are we
going to be what's gonna be our our
competitive advantage for other starters
being started right now and in thinking
about it just it seemed much more for us
at least people we're going to be our
core competency
I talk about a lot because I feel like
that is our are not only core competency
but our competitive advantage if you
think about in 2015 what can
differentiate or what can what can
change the vector of what a company can
accomplish it is the people it's not 90
95 Worth's its fundraising it's not 2005
where it's IP it is it's really none of
those things it's not it's not the
technology that you have or these moats
that you can just kind of arbitrarily
add to it the biggest thing that you can
do to affect this to being this in terms
of potency or impact of your companies
is get the best people possible we've
and we have yeah it's a won't go too
much into it but that is your brand
quite literally we think about it in
terms of we want to be the place where
people go to become better human beings
and be a brand that that can actually
live up to that so hiring people that
are you know collective average IQ 150
but also extremely awesome human beings
good human beings and really you know
wise i think my favorite definition
wisdom is knowing what's important out
of a thousand different variables what
is the most important one to answer your
question in 2015 for what we're building
it is the people that is the biggest
risk and as where we we put the most
thought into but it's also one of the
greatest things about the people we get
to work with this they look at the same
house in variables they come to the same
conclusion okay yeah right there more
about the mission and the company
necessarily but if at any point along
the process another company came along
that did do a Benetton tilt and was
threatening the business then you know
what would your next steps be would you
join them or try to outperform them or
so the question was if someone came
along and could could would have more
advocacy towards our mission than we
could what would we do would we join
them to be honest yo it's a developer
convention but it's when we think about
a lot its climbed the hill you're on and
so right now we focus on what we're
doing the next 90 days the next 12-18
months
on our customers a lot I've never really
thought about that hypothetical but
known us I bet we'd come up with a
pretty good plan of action but oh yeah
it's a good question i'll let you know
if it comes up all right thank you guys
you